[Music]
three
two
one
[Music]
the car smells really weird
there's a bomb under your seat
thank you for the information
don't even think about hanging up on me
so who are you what do you want get
together 3.4 million in cash some guy
just told me he's put a bomb in my car i
got the call too where are you now
it's a little like stepping on a
landmine
anyone gets out it explodes you contact
anyone it explodes piss me off
get
it
we're dead listen just hang in there
just in case all right
attention all units we have a private
banking center manager who manages vips
can't get a hold of 3.4 million i'm only
calling because uh it's about a 10
return on investment i handed you a deal
like that and you couldn't close it did
you forget i'm holding the detonator
step out of the vehicle
materials for homemade homes were found
right inside the suspect's home i
already told you not to hang up on me
get out of there
if you don't let me go i'll detonate the
bumpers
cannot get downtown
it's nice to finally meet you
always doing your best that's always
been your problem
if you just lived an ordinary life none
of this would have happened
[Music]
you